when sexual misconduct allegations were
made about the former deputy chief whip
Chris pincher it sent the government
into turmoil Boris Johnson the then
prime minister said he did not know
about the claims but one man Simon
McDonald a former civil servant wrote a
letter saying that he did Lord MacDonald
Has now written a book called leadership
and gives me his verdict on the leader's
past and present that he worked with
Lord McDonald thank you so much for
coming on the show and we're going to
talk a bit about this book which I'm
reading lessons about a life in
diplomacy a book on leadership and my
goodness me you've worked with quite a
few uh leaders in government you worked
at the foreign office for nearly four
decades
you were the most senior official at the
foreign office and one of the
government's top mandarins for five
years you've seen an awful lot you've
written the book about leadership in
which you talk about previous Prime
Ministers and how they handled the job
and this is a real treat for me because
typically civil servants never talk to
journalists so I'm feeling very spoiled
but of those Prime Ministers you served
who was the best and who was the worst
leader
good question bear
um and not a simple answer because they
were all good at some things and they
were all weak at some things and they
all or nearly all look better in the
rear view mirror so as I look back the
first one I was really conscious of was
Margaret Thatcher who was a very
difficult prickly character for the
system but who had a Clarity and a sense
of purpose and a sense of galvanizing
the system which looks to have been one
of our most effective prime ministers in
300 years then there was John Major who
at the time looked rather beleaguered
but was one of the most methodical men
I've ever seen where he went through the
breeze he knew exactly what he was going
to say in any international meeting then
we had Blair the best at communicating
you know in retrospect some of his
biggest policy calls were just wrong but
at the time the domestic policy the
island policy was right yeah Gordon
Brown the best at fine events but quite
a difficult Community he he bore his he
wore his anxieties on his face yeah and
when you're trying to lead people
through very difficult times to look as
though you're burdened it makes your
task more difficult uh Cameron ran a
team you know he looked the most at ease
in the job and uh he was some ways the
easiest to work for
Theresa May she was again a very
methodical person but with a very
difficult job that she didn't really
sympathize with she hadn't been a
brexiteer so that kind of hobbled her
from the start and then we had Boris
Johnson
foreign
okay one work okay you've given me all
these different I could give an
adjective for each of those leaders what
would be the one adjective you would
just use to describe to summarize Boris
Johnson as a leader
charismatic
okay that's a positive
negative chaotic chaotic charismatic and
chaotic Okay so we've got Thatcher as
difficult but effective we've got major
is a bit beleaguered we've got Blair the
communicator Cameron the team leader uh
Brown good at Finance but a bit anxious
and then you've got May encumbered by a
policy she didn't believe in but
methodical we've got Johnson
charismatic but chaotic who is the best
who is the worst
um Thatcher was the best and Johnson was
the worst okay
for those who've been talking what about
blur
a Blair I think will always be
remembered for Northern Ireland and the
Good Friday agreement was the single
most important agreement Within These
Isles in my lifetime but he will also be
remembered for Iraq and no matter how
much he believed in the prospectus at
the time I think looking back
it needs to be reappraised including by
himself let's just talk a bit if you
don't mind about Boris Johnson because
he he features in the book
um now civil servants live much of their
lives behind the scenes you don't really
talk to journalists it's kind of code of
conduct that you have to be utterly
discreet you're a diplomat I mean you
work in the shadows you'll never see
them
well did you want to be a spider if you
want to be a spy ever because I'm not
discreet enough okay but you did as a
former permanent section in fact you did
get involved in the raring golf in Boris
Johnson over the Chris pincher Affair
now just to quickly remind people this
was the deputy chief whip accused of
sexual misconduct back in July
government ministers publicly saying the
Prime Minister was unaware that he faced
such allegations in the past
um before putting him into that
sensitive job as deputy chief whip
you heard all of it what did you make of
it what did you think when you heard it
I heard it for five days uh and at the
beginning it seemed to me like a typical
number 10 operation where no matter the
problem the instant reaction was denial
uh quite adamant quite aggressive uh and
quite unbending but you know the the
pathology is this changes over time and
it did change over the following days
but they never came up with the truth
and there were two key facts which I
thought needed to be in the public
domain and which were still not in the
public domain the following Tuesday and
they were had there been allegations
before had they been investigated and
what was the outcome and second did the
Prime Minister know and the answers to
these two questions were yes and yes
because this has happened at the foreign
office yes a few years before he Chris
pincher was a junior Minister a very
similar allegation was made by members
of the foreign office they came to me
personally because it was very sensitive
and very unusual because it was
sensitive and unusual it was also very
memorable so I remembered each of the
steps I knew I kept the cabinet office
at the highest level informed and they
kept me informed about what they were
doing including with the prime minister
so the then foreign secretary Boris
Johnson we'll see them he was prime
minister and he was told yes and Simon
did you know the impact it would have
because it had big impact which we'll
get to did you appreciate at the time
when you made the intervention this is
going to be big frankly no you didn't
okay the last words I said to my wife
before I went to bed because my wife
made me sleep on it I'd written the
letter on the Monday evening she made me
sleep on it and as we were going to
sleep I said do you think anybody will
notice
well they did notice and his cabinet
notes which I'll come to but you then
found yourself a victim of quite a
vicious brief in war this is uh from The
Daily Telegraph on the 5th of July the
the morning the day that you released
this letter saying that it's not true
what number 10 is saying about what the
PM did and didn't know this is a former
minister they never saw eye to eye Simon
never made a secret the fact he was a
strong remainer and he has always had
big issues with brexit so now they're
playing the man not the ball
um there was a sense that this was some
sort of revenge on your part or you had
issues with Boris Johnson the lead in
brexiteer what what would you say to
those allegations how did that feel for
you is it really unpleasant it was
unpleasant but much less unpleasant than
what um the victims of the various
Pinscher scandals had undergone
um uh and it was wrong and I knew it was
wrong I mean I have already said I was a
remainer and I made that plane to the
then foreign secretary and prime
minister but what was more important was
doing the job for the government and I
believe I did that and the foreign
office did that but someone was there
any extent to which you were opposed to
his political project and you did want
to get rid of him no
absolutely not uh I I hope I'm smiling
because the the idea that civil servants
sit around and plot who should be in
charge is just not true but but you
didn't like I mean the book trips with
animosity I have to say and you you
didn't like the guy right you didn't
think he was up to the job that's fair
isn't it they're two different points
Beth uh on a personal level Boris
Johnson was always
Charming to deal with he was humorous he
was kind he was the person the foreign
secretary I worked with Who had most
time for the people in his office
including in his outer office and this
is a real Mark of a character but what
you Need to Be an Effective prime
minister is different being prime
minister is one of the toughest jobs in
the world and one of the surprises to me
is that in modern British politics so
many people think they are qualified to
pitch for this most difficult and most
examining of job and he wasn't in your
view qualified I other people will judge
but I think as he contemplates his three
years as prime minister he probably
would concede that he did not achieve
what he hopes it's like so you said I
mean extremely charismatic and he he
genuinely is a charismatic leader who
can reach parts of the lecturer you know
that other concern loved his can't reach
other politicians can't reach he said he
was chaotic
what other traits did you see in him
that made you think this is a really
hard job and you're not up to it so
chaotic what else the chaotic was he
liked to have multiple opinions swirling
around him and then and the people
proposing those ideas never really knew
whose was in the lead and where the
decision would be and sometimes the
decision wasn't clear and sometimes the
decision was reversed so there was a
there was too much swirl and in the end
the the system responds to clearer
Direction but your your intervention was
decisive you you are the civil servant
that brought down a prime minister I
mean the resignation started that night
from his cabinet you are you are I am
I'm a footnote uh my history teacher who
features in the book told me the
difference between occasion of events
and the causes of events the causes that
brought down Boris Johnson had been laid
long before my tweet okay so you say you
weren't the cause that you know you you
know you weren't the cause you were the
occasion I I read that in the book but
you were still the trigger okay
you accept that I accept that mine was
the final straw that made it onto the
Johnson's camels back first but you did
open the flood date because it was after
your letter and I remember listening to
the radio that morning and thinking
blimey this is because because you don't
intervene and that you did
it did trigger a series of events in
which both Sajid Javid and then Rishi
sunak resigned from cabinet that night
then dozens more resignations by
Wednesday night the Prime Minister
insisted he was going to stay Thursday
morning he had no option
um but to go but Beth all I did was
insist on two facts to be acknowledged
and the fact that they had not been
acknowledged for the previous five days
turned out to be important and but you
then tweeted out if you you tweeted out
a picture of Westminster at Sunset and
you said it had been good you you
mentioned in the book it's been a good
day there we go that there it was a good
day
um it did make it sound like a personal
animus a bit that you you had your
reasons he pushed you out of the foreign
office he chose to merge the Departments
I mean it was pretty brutal the way you
got shoved out after a very long and
successful career
I supported the merger very very
strongly now Beth as I look at that
tweet uh and think about all the
reactions that is something I would do
differently ah okay but at the time I
was reacting to the negative briefing
right you know the whole system
everything around the Prime Minister had
become so personal and disagreeable so
that in that moment with that rather
lovely view it did feel like so it was a
good day so you
so the personal briefings did get you a
bit and you did this Did you sort of
wish you hadn't done this now well you
said you do it differently I would
um because
uh I didn't want it to be personal it
wasn't personal I was trying to
establish important facts and the fact
that that tweet obscures that
means that I misfired but it also shows
that you were heart hurt and human yeah
yeah heart and human and had horrible
briefings against you before we move on
though
um
what were you thinking when it looked
like Boris Johnson was potentially going
to return as prime minister over that
weekend where it looked like he was
going to make another Tilt at the job
were you were you alarmed by that yes
um
it just seemed incredible to me that
people who had lived through all of 2022
who had lived through that dramatic week
in July who had precipitated Boris
Johnson's downfalls so the Parliamentary
conservative party would just three or
four months later forget all the
negative side and think you know we'll
give him a second chance
and the thing that most puzzled me was
the line that Boris Johnson has learned
his lesson
whereas one thing I think Boris Johnson
has always been clear and consistent
about is that he he is who he is you
take him as he is and he does not and
will not change
so I was very surprised that uh more
than a hundred conservative MPS had
forgotten that but should there ever be
a way back for him or you think not of
course there can be of course he can
have prime minister tilt
um
I quote Enoch Powell and others that
there are no second acts in British
politics so it would be a surprise but
he has that option it would take a lot
of hard work and he would have to put
other priorities on hold so he wouldn't
be able to devote so much time to the
speaker circuit in the USA he'd have to
devote a lot of time to his constituency
and to Parliament and now we have
or we had less trust I mean you say in
the book that you'd hoped that civility
honesty and personal responsive
responsibility would come with the
arrival of a new prime minister what did
you make of Liz truss's short
Premiership were you
what was your view of how you you'd work
with her before as well hadn't you only
at one remove and our conversation about
good Prime Ministers ended too soon or
bad Prime Ministers I think if the list
includes Liz trusswell then she was a
worse prime minister than Boris Johnson
because she started and made two
immediate irrevocable mistakes the first
was excluding from her government
anybody who had not supported her to the
hilt and the second was running a budget
a mini budget that was ideologically
driven and before launching that budget
taking care that she could not hear
would not receive any contrary advice
you Boris Johnson also did that by the
way he he put into cabinet he he created
a government around him that were full
of his backers and not his
detractors
true but he had led the party to its
biggest election victory since Margaret
Thatcher Liz truss had not one thing she
did do though was she did secure the
release of nazneen zagari Radcliffe now
did she ride on the success of others
hard work successive or her predecessors
or was she genuinely a politician that
could get things done she pays tribute
to the work of her predecessors I mean
Jeremy Hunt in particular devoted
himself to nazanin zagari Radcliffe's
case so it was the culmination of a lot
of people's hard work and Liz truss was
there when the moment came just quickly
before I move on
all of this talk in the run-up to this
moment where Liz truss became prime
minister they talked about treasury
Orthodoxy did you see that as code for
disregarding the civil service order did
you see it as a
a sort of sign of attack on Whitehall
well it was certainly an attack on the
treasury it was an attack on constraints
it was an attack on things that uh Liz
truss and her team believed had been
holding back the United Kingdom but they
learned very quickly that their analysis
was not a complete analysis but was
there anything more the Civil Service
could have done to avert the crisis you
know like does this also always take
some responsibility or are you merely ex
executors of your political Masters if
you like the deal is civil servants
advise and ministers to decide so all
the decisions of Liz truss's government
were hers and her ministers
well I want to just we we've partless
trust and Boris Johnson quickly Rishi
sunak where would you put him in your
your leadership uh League table
one of the methodical ones as you say
unproven but promising raw material very
promising promising okay so Ivy I feel
awkward as a civil servant assets
there we go another critical from policy
issue of your time was the Iraq War and
you come pretty close in this book
saying that Tony Blair lied you you talk
about that moment where in the chilcott
inquiry that letters uncovered where he
says to President Bush I will be with
you whatever do you think he lied no I
think that the intelligence picture
comprehensively misled him and it's
quite critical of that I'm sure he at
every step Joe during the run-up and
through the conflict he believed what he
was saying because there were was
documentary evidence intelligence to
support it but but Simon you also talk
in the book about leaders the best
leaders being able to make mistakes
admit their mistakes
um with the reference to Blair's
insistent that the Iraq War was not a
disaster do you think he struggles to
admit his mistakes even now even as time
has passed yes you do I think
um there's still time for him to look
again but even all these years later he
I believe defends what he did further
than the facts support you think that
that's poor leadership
an aspect but he did many other things
what is it about him is it is it
arrogant is it arrogance is it
self-belief is it doesn't want to admit
it to himself it's a human thing the
things the decisions that are biggest in
our lives we are most attached to uh if
it turns out they were wrong decisions
it's very very difficult as a human
being to admit it and I what if you
indulge I've gone massively over time as
ever but this is such a fascinating
conversation I just want to finish on
Putin I
find this section in the book
fascinating when you talk about Tony
Blair's final G8 Summit is you're not in
you'll know that I'm referring to it's
2007 and he meets Putin and Putin
signals in this conversation a
reassertion of Russian influence and
aggression and dissatisfaction with the
post-cold war setup and the way in which
he perceives Russia has been treated or
rather sort of mistreated by the west
and those leaders 15 years ago do you
think that they ever understood the
significance of that moment or did they
ever take him seriously
they took him seriously but they
misread the signals from 2007 which
started in a big speech in Munich at the
security conference in February but then
as the year went on he he was saying
this more and more clearly and the
following year he invaded Georgia and
ever since then we have seen a ramping
up of Russian operations externally
Crimea in 2014 was enormously important
but kind of downplayed so when we look
back we in the west must see that we
contributed to him overreaching in
February 2022. is that one of your
biggest regrets when you look back on
your time in the foreign office is that
one of your biggest regrets that they've
kind of
perhaps
Leaders The Establishment didn't see
what was coming or was it seen But for
other political reasons wasn't acted
upon we did some very good things on
Russia policy I think after the screepal
poisoning the British system with Boris
Johnson as The Foreign secretary led the
world's reaction never before have 30
countries coordinated expulsion of spies
but when you measure what we were doing
against the challenge that we now see
well then clearly we fell short but Beth
I think this applies in other areas of
policy right now I think we're falling
short in our climate response you know
something we talk about we know is
important cop 27 is happening right now
but I suspect in 10 20 years when we
look back we'll think okay we were doing
some stuff but we really weren't doing
enough is that one area though where you
think Boris Johnson can take some credit
that he did try and galvanize
momentum on climate yeah cop 26 was the
biggest uh such conference since the
Paris uh conference in 2016 uh so all
2015. so yes he did show leadership and
it was you know the awful circumstances
of the end of the coffee that meant that
it was uh smaller and less impactful
than he wanted and and so my final
question to you
do you think that a cornered Putin might
reach for tactical nuclear weapons
I understand his rationale in spooking
us
I do not believe it works for Russia
actually to deploy such weapons they
would lose all their support starting
with most important China so I think
when Putin is looking at an actual
decision he will decide not to use
nuclear weapons what adjective would you
use to describe Putin as a leader
cold calculating
scary dangerous dangerous for sure okay
well look thank you so much Simon
McDonald Lord McDonald for coming in to
talk about your book and it was really
enjoyable to talk to you fascinating
thank you thank you Beth thank you